montenegro on the sparkling adriatic
coast in the 1980s it was a magnet for
the rich and famous the country is
hoping to build on that legacy in recent
years a number of luxury hotels have
been built along the coast that's led to
a huge demand for water the country has
already invested a lot of money in
modern water infrastructure as tourism
booms but all the waste water needs to
be treated sewage treatment plants are
still being built a pump station is
under construction a few metres behind
the hotels of hajek novi it's meant to
divert the treated wastewater into the
ocean plus the german engineer URMC glow
is in charge of the site for the entire
wastewater disposal system the aim is to
prevent untreated wastewater from being
discharged directly into the ocean the
coastal towns are investing more than
150 million euros in the entire water
supply and sewage treatment system the
biggest investment in 30 years a large
chunk was financed by Germany's
International Development Bank the KfW
djokovic manages the various water
infrastructure plants with the KfW in
montenegro he's worried about the
timeline
this sea outfall pipe has to be laid a
thousand meters out into the ocean
before the tourists arrive that's an
eternity this is a discharge pipe line
for the treatment plant through which
treated sewage is pumped into the ocean
at a depth of 35 meters divers are to
fasten the pipes onto the ocean floor so
they aren't washed away by the current
the clock is ticking in a few days the
beaches here will be full of tourists
tourism is Montenegro's biggest source
of revenue but more tourists also means
higher power consumption the electricity
comes from Montenegro hinterland one of
Europe's most water rich regions clean
hydropower meets almost seventy percent
of the country's power requirements but
demand is increasing the country's
largest hydropower plant is located at
the piva reservoir the damn walls are
200 metres high for decades it's been
supplying a large amount of Montenegro's
electricity but the facility is now
outdated and is being retrofitted with
the help of kfw loans but its opening
the sofia it's important for the future
to extend the lifespan of the plant by
30 years the power plant is 37 years old
even with the best maintenance its
service life is at an end some of its
components are finished so basically the
safety of the plant is our top priority
in second place extending its service
life and the most important thing is the
environmental compatibility generating
green power
greenpower mitigates huge carbon
emissions caused by firing coal or oil
after retrofitting the power plant is
expected to produce even more clean
electricity for that the first of three
water turbines is shut down it's a
tricky procedure because of the huge
water pressure but important components
urgently need replacing so the plant can
continue to generate power reliably for
the decades ahead in the control room
the technicians are nervous hoping
everything will work out smoothly
the first turbine is now in place and
ready for retrofitting in the months
ahead the other two will go through the
same procedure the control system will
be completely replaced then a fully
retrofitted power plant will hopefully
operate without blackouts but not
everyone is happy with the power plant
even though it's meant to generate clean
electricity that's because back in the
1970s building the reservoir involved
flooding the historic town of perugia
name mirko Vuckovich remembers how he
lost everything he and his family and
the entire village were relocated he
says all they got was symbolic
compensation yessum rajan nadeznha yo
buleria k pv i grew up on the right
shore of the piva this lake was flooded
38 years ago before that the piva was a
wonderful mountain river sabine in
canyon obsidian Isaiah Serena yessum I
was born here yes our house was over
there the old settlements were there
really started pushing in our solicitor
now the town of blue Gina is up there
everything back there is underwater over
70 meters deep under City 3 meter back
on the other side of the mountains on
the coast the Bay of Kotor is a UNESCO
World Heritage Site
the historic center of town is full of
tourists the twelve hundred year old
cathedral is the main attraction in
summer there are three times more
tourists than residents
the tourists are good for montenegro but
not for its environment with german help
montenegro is now preparing for the
future not just by investing in harbors
and luxury hotels but also an effective
water and power infrastructure